and unsurprising news the online
component of GTA 5 is continuing to make
a butt ton of cash for its parent
company take two I'm Lucy add welcome to
this game spot news heist speaking this
week during an earnings briefing take to
CEO Strauss Zelnick said the players
continue to be highly engaged with GTA
online while he didn't share any
specific numbers he revealed that GTA
online more than two years after its
release had its best week ever for both
revenue and active players this past
holiday before the holiday season GTA
online was seeing around eight million
players per week continuing with his
buzzwords Zelnick said that this
sustained engagement was partially
attributable to develop a rockstar
steady stream of free add-on content and
in-game events specifically calling out
the Halloween and Christmas updates as
well as executives and other criminals
and lowriders all for being key
contributors to the games record results
but will GTA online slowdown in 2016
probably not in fact Zelnick said take
two is now forecasting the GTA online
revenue will actually increase year over
year another GTA 5 news take two
announced this week that the game has
shipped 60 million copies single-player
dlc for GTA 5 is still under
consideration but these incredible
numbers for GTA online may explain why
Rockstar might not be rushing to get it
out of the door anytime soon so are you
still playing and enjoying GTA online
let me know in the comments below or
come find me on Twitter I met Lucy James
games for all the latest on GTA 5 make
sure to keep it gamespot
you